titien via cri de colère cris d'alarmé
en tout cas mené par des autonomes vous
étiez vous très virulente dans
l'hémicycle on se rappelle vous vouliez
vraiment qu'on aille au bout du
processus et fiable on se retrouve avec
un processus presque à moitié à risque
il faut voir le verre à moitié vide à
moitié plantes dites nous tout alors
d'abord je soulignerai que c'est un
point des alertes de la déontologue et
c'est un point d' alerte qui était
antérieure à la version définitive du
dispositif françois d'origine a rappelé
après ce point dallaire d'un certain
nombre d'éléments ont été améliorés et
il est notamment préconisée et c'est
vrai c'est quelque chose moi que je
recommande également de faire appel à un
expert comptable pour tenir une
comptabilité précise avait pris d'emblée
en compte les remarques de la
déontologue vous avez exact réagissent
et ça coûte exactement elle a été
consultée c'est normal elle n'a pas les
moyens à elle seule de pouvoir contrôler
une comptabilité d'autres voilà est
d'autant plus que les députés n'ont pas
tous l'habitude alors nous qui venons de
la société civile c'est vrai moi j'suis
professions libérales je vais tenir une
comptabilité je sais qu'à un certain
nombre de mes collègues n'ont pas
l'habitude de tenir cette comptabilité
il vaut mieux qu'il fasse appel à un
expert comptable qui va organiser cela
de manière claire et qui permettra la
déontologue de faire son travail
correctement la réforme prévoit que 120
députés enfin une centaine de députés
soient tirés au sort qu est ce que vous
croyez laetitia via aux vertus du hasard
dans ce domaine vous savez ce hasard
c'est celui que vivent l'ensemble
aujourd'hui des chefs d'entreprise ou
des professions libérales le contrôle de
nos frais et de notre comptabilité est
également hasardeuse concept un contrôle
fiscal il y à la tenue de la
comptabilité et rigoureux il faut le
faire tous les ans mais ensuite le
contrôle c'est hasardeux et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut être toujours au clair et
avoir une comptabilité lab la
comptabilité la plus parfaite possible
pour ne pas avoir de contrôler et de
régularisation après vous qu'on se
souvient dans l'hémicycle pendant ces
nuits où l'assemblée a siégé pour faire
adopter les lois de moralisation qui
prévoient ces règles eh bien vous
souhaitiez un contrôle quand même assez
strictes que chaque dépense finalement
soit soit justifiée comme cela oui comme
ma jambe en bretagne pas en juin c'est
long je me retrouve dans le même système
que celui que je vis depuis huit ans que
je suis avocate et c'est exactement ce
que j'ai dit dans l'hémicycle c'est que
je ne vois pas pourquoi il y aurait une
différence entre un député est une
personne professions libérales ou hors
de mon prix ce qui doit justifier de ses
frais
depuis le 18 juin donc depuis que je
suis élu je garde l'ensemble de mes
factures ce sera toujours le cas
j'organise une comptabilité cette
comptabilité peut-être
vérifier c'est ça le plus important
c'est qu'il y ait un contrôle et une
obligation vraiment de justifier de
l'ensemble des frais luan moralisation
qui faisait partie un petit peu de tout
ça des réformes voulues par le président
de l'assemblée nationale suffisant aux
yeux des français pour approcher le
politique et les français selon vous
vous savez il y as a voulu parler de
notes de frais
des sciences aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de la
sphère politique on ne sait et cet
éloignement il faut lutter contre 6 il
faut aller plus loin moi je suis tout à
fait volontaire vraiment apporter
toujours un système qui peut aller plus
loin françois de rugy a bien dit qu'il
était ouvert à une évaluation d'ici un
an sur ce terreau non ce qu'on peut
faire de plus ce que c'est ça le plus
important c'est drôle toujours dans le
but de rapprocher les sétois voilà
exactement c'est l'élément le plus
important et s'il faut aller plus loin
dans un contrôle systématique avec
peut-être un service comptable plus
conséquent au sein de l'assemblée
peut-être pour aider à cela vous ayez
bien oui je serai aux volontaires
vraiment pour porter également ses
réformes